- I'm pretty sure that mom
was trying to bang her son.
- Wait, wait, the hot chick
was Alex P. Keaton's mom?
- Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
- But they're the same age.
- No, but he went back in time.
- Then why is it called
Back to the Future?
- He has to go back to the
future because he's in the past,
so the future is actually the
present, which is his time.
- What?
(upbeat music)
- What did I tell you!?
88 miles per hour!
(gun firing)
(intense music)
(upbeat music)
- Use the shampoo and the conditoner
and when your hair is
damp, it's not wet, okay,
when it's damp--
- Damp.
- You do four puffs of
the Farrah Fawcett spray.
- Farrah Fawcett spray?
- Yeah, Farrah Fawcett.
You tell anyone I just told you that
and your ass is grass,
you're dead, you understand?
- Yep.
(party horns blowing)
(screaming)
(upbeat music)
- I dump your ass.
- I'd like you to meet Cerebro.
- What exactly are we looking at here?
(upbeat music)
- Girls go to science camp?
- Suzie does, she's a genius.
- Is she cute?
- Think Phoebe Cates, only hotter.
- No way, hotter than Phoebe Cates?
- Mhmm.
- No.
(crashing)
- [Steve] God damnit.
(upbeat music)
- Stacey?
- Yeah?
- (clears throat) Shall we?
- Um, no thanks.
(upbeat music)
(can opening)
- Quiet.
- Oh, sorry.
- How do you even drink that?
- Because it's delicious.
- What?
- It's like Carpenter's The Thing.
The original is the classic.
No question about it.
But the remake...
(sips)
(sighs) Sweeter, bolder, better.
(upbeat music)
- [Dustin] Suzie, do you copy?
Suzie, do you copy?
(upbeat music)
- Hey.
- Hi.
- Does your species like M&Ms?
(slow music)
- It will recharge.
- I know it will, kid, I know.
- I can fight.
- Better than any of us.
(slow music)